that's why I always say shoot first
situal situational awareness later thank
you thank you finally someone for mine
now where am I exactly
what happened
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to an amazing
episode of the careful boys today we
have Mr skulls dang goes down
by far but we did want to avoid talking
about you for now and talk about Colleen
all right checking in with Colleen
checking in with Colleen it's a new
segment that we've been trying but she
always shoots me down we just constantly
run this video yeah yeah and now Nick's
the moderating interviewer oh good
that's not fair today
I didn't consent to this well you don't
like his questions he's good she kind of
doesn't like my question she called me a
[__] idiot earlier holy [__] let's
see you [__] said it dude
good [__] go ahead first question yeah
this is great good content how does it
feel
what what's up with your car how did you
find your car good question thank you
what's up with their car yeah yeah hold
on I'm trying to great question even
worse delivery how does it feel what's
up with their car
yeah that's my question please answer it
okay so two and a half days after my car
was stolen they found it in East L.A
five minutes away from JK news whoa how
do you feel about that uh I feel like
I know that's like that's like an hour
from where it was stolen by the way yeah
it is do you have it back no so it was
stripped oh okay
um insurance company declared it a total
loss yeah
um and I got a new car oh cool okay they
test it for like semen and stuff like
that whoa I feel like they do that in
all the movies they don't give up they
do a seaming test honestly the uh I had
to go to the police station get a slip
just
um get a release for my car because it's
like a high security tow company that
works with the police station you don't
know nothing about that you already know
I had never I was like tripping out I
had never been to a place like this
before and I was like whoa this is like
super high security
and um so I get in there my brother and
I are looking at my car I pop up in the
Hood the car is messed up it smells like
smoke they left a bunch of stuff in
there well they leave um like just
random like some random person's hat
some napkins some food but like what
about semen um just to be clear no semen
in the car was it a fitted or a snapback
yeah Ron can test it for you too great
guys good questions uh but it was
stripped down like did it have doors or
no wheels the outside looked fine
everything looked fine on the outside of
the car but it was when you pop open the
hood they changed the battery the other
things are missing like wait they were
nice enough to actually put another
battery in yeah well I think as they
they put like a shitty battery in just
to get it to a place to drop it off to
get it to move and then to
to leave but there's things that I'm
glad they didn't take which is pretty on
brand for criminals like they didn't
take
um books they didn't take they're not
read or something exactly you know what
kind of books did you have in there only
intelligent ones stupid people wanna you
know right so you wouldn't recognize
them yeah you wouldn't recognize them
don't ask for them dude I read books
like my dad's chess pieces that I had in
my car two so you have sentimental stuff
yeah mental stuff oh good thing that was
still there I know my hiking boots they
didn't take they're not into nature yeah
no elevation basically anything chess
related books or nature they're like I
feel like if we were to steal that car
we would have taken that stuff instead
of the other stuff I was like dude check
out these boots dude we could go hiking
with them guys like us yeah yeah what
was the other stuff outside of like car
stuff that they might have taken
um I did have like a hiking backpack in
there I had
um like a Leatherman in there I had any
of your like
I'm like super diligent on always taking
my stuff out of my car I'll never leave
because I've had too many friends get
their stuff stolen do you ever leave
snacks in your car no I eat them but
okay sometimes another stupid question
Nick come on jeez I leave snacks in my
car sometimes yeah and I'd be and what
kind of conversations did that lead you
to you
[Laughter]
Nick you're blowing up
in my car they left like a half eating
popcorn bag like it was awesome I just
want to know if they ate the snacks
that's it
that's all I wanted to know sorry sorry
for asking is there a new car better
than the old one way better oh cool way
better yeah come on yeah come on I mean
I still like lost out on like you know
the money that I originally invested
into that car and I didn't obviously get
like the full full amount that I could
have gone for the value of the card
because it was still being financed so I
got the difference at least there was a
difference yeah oh yeah yes you know
yeah could have been worse yeah I was
insured I did have comprehensive
insurance so thankfully
um you know which is crazy that you
didn't know well yeah that's so crazy
why well here's the thing okay my theory
is that I was going through so many
different things in my life just so many
things back to back happening that I
think my brain just Auto defaulted to
worst case scenario and I was just like
yep I probably have the worst coverage
the worst coverage is this is not going
to be the you know I was trying to
problem solve for the worst case
scenario got it yeah so but it ended up
being a lot better than yeah I was gonna
ask that because
um when I got my car broken into when
you get it back it doesn't feel the same
no and you know what because someone
else invaded your stuff yeah you're like
I was praying Insurance Company
I was like if they declared a total
oh yeah and then I was like praying and
I was talking to Ryan's like no I'm
pretty sure they're going to yeah thank
God too and I was like I'm praying that
they do because I don't want that card
back after seeing it and like I was like
go through your [__] and they ransack
your [__] which has happened to me in
many cars energy in that car it was just
hell
sure
man
you're gonna get like half the value for
the car there's a massive amount it's
like man this guy really knows what he's
talking about so much time though
because you're like I think oh [__] gosh
all right hold on
oh okay that much time it's the act of
stealing they're getting off on yeah
yeah we gotta shoot some ropes in that
thing you know yeah
oh the hiking backpack
but it was crazy though it was like two
weeks after that my neighbor same
parking garage their car got stolen and
then like eight other cars were broken
into is it because that key is easy to
break into so they're targeting this
position no so what's happening is the
um Kias and Hyundai is between 2015 and
2019 they have a compromise security
system so basically all you need is a
USB oh yeah that's been a popular thing
yeah it's a trend there's a there's a
viral trend on Tick Tock yeah so that
went viral and then now
um I'm a victim of the Kia boys here we
go way to go great jumping on the truck
but there's been a class action lawsuit
and I think it finally went through good
yeah Jesus Christ I mean it's not going
to be years before I even see anything
did you know the Kia or you got
something yeah I definitely doubled down
you did yeah I was like with a big sign
that says like please steal me again it
has a USB port on the outside is it
outside of those years no hell no I got
a Mazda CX-5 let's go baby Mazda I got
Mazda dude monsters are tight yeah so
what is a security situation like at
your place now
um it's the illusion of security that's
cool holographic dogs exactly
yeah we have uh we have a uh we don't
have security we have patrols off site
Patrol off-site Patrol yeah yep
everything's good over there yeah that's
what the fifth is I'll check over there
it's [__] it's just offside Patrol
um really cool
basically is like if you if you see
something you call them and then they'll
come or they only come like an hour like
three hours out of the day but it's like
morning yeah everybody's coming
everywhere why even have any Patrol at
all so yeah someone's gonna steal my car
in an hour
so we don't really have something
um and it's a private owner who owns the
apartment complex
um and I've actually spoken to them
about this is he pretty chill
seems like a good guy
do you have any like additional like the
club or at a alarm I don't know any
other I have a well in this new car that
I have now I have a low Jack and I also
have an additional tracker hidden in the
car damn what are you carrying with you
every day
um I have pepper spray a knife I have a
taser at home and other firearms
here we see it now you have your knife
on you huh do you have your knife on you
uh it's in the car
I think knives are cool bro I want to
see what kind of what kind of knife you
pack no but we also have like
um I've gotten to know a lot of the
neighbors too we have like a little
group of us there's an ex-military dude
got a militia going it was like scoping
out the place now we have other people
who are like literally waiting in their
cars with their guns like we really want
to catch these guys because it's just
been
non-stop oh everyone's been getting like
targeted yes like um cars been broken
into guns have been stolen cars have
been guns stolen bro um some dude was
like lurking and I think one of the
ex-military military dudes caught him
beat his ass
um which is like a set of trap everybody
should pitch in for like a use Kia Soul
and just have it sit there unlocked get
some paint cans movie a door slightly
open a big car we're already doing it
come everywhere we're already doing it
oh man he grabs it you know what's crazy
so um
you know it's a really nice neighborhood
and then there was like during covet and
stuff so there was like crazy like a
little theft ring going on
someone's uh car got taken out of there
just straight out of their driveway and
so everyone in like the neighborhood
group chat was like hey don't do you
have cameras you have cameras and
they're like yeah but the they have like
camera scramblers now nice so like a
black Accord pulls up you see two people
get out of the car and then the next
thing is the car that was on the
driveway is gone
whoa so they have that like they have
they come with tools so like even though
you have your camera it's not recording
the crime because they already know how
to disable your camera before they get
there then they have people that have
garage door openers yeah so you can
reprogram them they're really easy yeah
so they just go around opening
everyone's garages and it's like what
the [__] I did learn a lot from the
situation like I learned how to like
reprogram like Garage openers where to
get them I also know how to like
basically steal any car you want to
start yeah let's do it
um steal them back these are villain
origin story like I know how to like
reprogram car keys now too wow
um so it's I mean that's kind of cool I
think you'll never use it I'll never use
it but I think I I wanted to learn that
information in order to like make a
logical assessment to like what car
should I get and then how to prevent it
how to steal it and how to steal money
yeah and how to steal like so uh this
dealership's got this cool car that I
want I know I know how to steal this
[__] who do you think who thinks Ryan's
sitting here is like I don't know
I only know how to do stuff to old cars
new [__] I have no clue he's like [__]
this USB stuff I hot wire you just need
a specific computer and you go through
like the OBD2 port and then you copy the
code that the key the original key is
transmitting which everybody should get
like a a blocker that you put over your
key because your key is always
transmitting that code but only your car
is reading that code because it's synced
up together oh like when you go into the
parking lot you go like this like it's
technically it's sending everywhere it's
sending everywhere but your car and that
key transmitter is communicating only
with each other wow so you have to copy
that code that the transmitter is giving
out through a computer and then buy a
different key and why am I telling them
yeah you got that I mean you can just
figure this out for yourself but this is
exactly what happened with like the
whole Kia situation like news articles
are being like so like uh a lot of the
cars are getting stolen this is how you
do it but it could be like someone with
that that computer is probably just
sitting in a parking lot somewhere and
waiting for someone to get to their car
and they're like yeah so even in your
house they say even if like your keys
are on your
to the wall if they can
they usually get that code that
transmitter code through the house and
they can just be like okay cool we have
X amount of codes that are being sent
through the computer let's just program
this uh new key fob and then test it out
that's why they say don't hang your keys
on the inside of your garage you know
some people like they'll get out of the
car just hang it right there that's the
worst place those are marks dude those
are [__] idiots because all you have
to do is when you steal a car you just
check the [__] the what you call it
the visor there's the keys baby oh
that's
that [__] always in trucks like an old
pickup always has that bro it's just at
an abandoned gas station you look at the
guy that you're still in the car with
you're like I can't believe that worked
and then you take off dude they stole my
neighbor's car with one of those things
that uh that balances the signal like a
Wi-Fi extender
from his garage to his car like two guys
it's all he sent the video to our whole
neighborhood so you guys like it looks
so casual they just like walk up one guy
stands by the garage the other guy just
goes drove away you just can't trust
anything electronic these days I mean
you just gotta like protect it
so you just got to get blockers you need
a moat around your [__] house now
dude what I need to do is
are you planning on moving
I'm not gonna say anything say it now
say it now I'm gonna say anything say
Vegas Vegas you should go to Vegas you
said it no I don't know would you say
that this is like a moment in your life
where you uh have like the most
consistent like I don't know fear is the
right word but like you know your safety
is always questioned yeah I feel like
I'm always in fight or flight mode when
I go home
um and just extra cautious which is just
like disrupted my piece a lot yeah
um so yeah that sucks so this video is a
GoFundMe for Colleen oh my gosh
it's for this whole side of the room
come on come on and then believe all
women side huh and us where would she be
without that donate to patreon you'd be
calling her a bald-faced liar yeah I
know that that definitely sucks yeah I
always feel
that yeah that does suck so you know
hopefully maybe I move and or maybe it
stops
I kind of gotten used to it though too
you got tips man you can [__] handle
anybody yeah Security Guys yeah freshman
fight back because my personal security
guard for the next month
gonna be my standard stuff I always tell
everybody is situation awareness body
language and voice uh most people when
crime is happening when attacks happen
towards them because they're unaware of
their environment and so if you're aware
of maybe someone's scoping out your car
because a lot of times they don't just
randomly hey let's get that one they're
researching for quite a bit you know I
remember a long time ago my girlfriend
got a cardinal at a Walmart and she
noticed some weird dude kept on
following her she didn't think anything
of it and they sure enough she went out
to the parking lot her car was gone wow
I feel like I'm too aware now I feel
like that's just like it's like Overkill
um yeah that's just what like is
consuming my life and what I'm focused
on because it took something very
valuable to you totally
um and also it's just a hot spot on my
place
um if everyone's cars yeah targeted
everything yes that's why I always say
shoot first situal situational awareness
later thank you thank you finally
someone from mine now where am I exactly
what happened you can put a kill switch
on your car true yeah oh yeah a what a
kill switch a kill switch yeah um I have
a kill switch on all my yeah how does
that work well because they're old it's
very easy to install things that cut off
all the battery power so what do you
like do you can operate the kill switch
remotely or how does that hidden it's
hidden somewhere different in every car
so some of them you have to reach into
the air vent of the AC and hit a switch
and then you could drive the car and
then it'll turn on yeah so it just won't
even work that's really cool that's like
that's the old school tried and true way
like it still applies today maybe it's
like the 40s basically really cool and
you know what see I don't know about
like like new cars I don't know how you
kill switch those but old ones are mad
easy new ones are pretty good but like
she's saying they're transponders as
long as you they haven't they have a
blocker box that you can put it in and
it blocks all signals so they can't
bounce off of that so you just have to
buy this box the kill switch on my 79
Camaro was beautiful because it's a it's
the neck of the steering wheel
you have to twist it this way and it
goes click and then you can start the
car so it's not even a switch it's like
the whole column when you sold the cars
you tell them like yeah he took it out
too the guy that bought it what idiot
dude didn't need it lives on a farm oh
damn that's so cool though [__] dude
and he's a firefighter he's way cooler
than me randomly on some cars like this
Toyota Corolla and this during this
range here there's a kill switch but the
kill switch was to hold the high beam
light so you can start the car and if
you don't hold the hopper we'll start I
found it out like last month I was
trying to like start somebody's cars
like it's not starting oh you don't know
how to start the car I was like I I
don't I'm sorry this is like pull the
Highlight beam what do you mean the
height how would you know that oh my God
if you ever get into repo you're gonna
have to start learning a little bit more
I didn't know that so I was like she's
helping you repo her car yeah I was like
I was like no way that just freaking
worked I'm like what the fudge but it
came from the factory like that yeah so
I thought that would be a customizable
for sure what the hell wow so this range
of Toyota Corollas uh from Toyota
don't go any further until we know
dude even even I have a school well I
had a scooter I just sold it but there
was a false start switch you know like
the the start the engine yeah it doesn't
actually do anything the real switch is
behind the seat and it's freaking the
size of a rice screen
flick it yeah
and then it goes oh
good exhaust is that I want it
people think of all kinds of really cool
things and I bought it like that the guy
was like yeah it's my anti-theft that's
pretty smart that's smart
yeah
um stats that I know every 33 seconds in
California or I think it's La specific a
car is the one yeah
I get out my Toyota Corolla from Japan
[Laughter]
[Music]